hi some here the apple store and it's
kind of cool if you got all these clips
of African safari on here so I'm gonna
show you something here our first clip
we're going to cut you a lion flies on
this space okay so here's the lion and
he has a lot of flies on its face as you
can see there's one right there flying
around oh and whose nose is so big E
actually if I wanted to make my home I
could probably make my home inside of
his nostril there listen son we ever
have business daddy son bonding time
look at this I know being might not be
enjoying this please put a smile on your
face so that everybody watching thanks
to having a good time and I'm a good dad
I like this as much as you think I enjoy
sitting here by the beach swaying back
and forth I am a hammock and I paint my
life this sucks could somebody please
come here and stood on me things spent
one of the holidays and Prince and this
is my brother my brother we hung out in
his baby according it was so pretty he's
really good and this is my other brother
he likes you
okay actually there's there's no rush
really sure what so ever and that's kid
on a tire swing see what else we got
here i'm seeing these little kids
running around no hey guys i'm just
hanging out here i have a little plug on
my face i just can't get rid of it I
just won't pay papers on my friend we're
not friends o our friends doing oh hey
guys hey we're just checking out the
scene here we're just hanging out you on
a prairie yeah I'm having so much fun I
just don't even know the deal hey guys
you just don't like to be near seriously
you just have no idea it's like a walk
amok amok and my feet just keep on a
hurtin I'll see you guys later I got
something to do I thought this was a
living a fun vacation and then my
boyfriend's left me and now I'm here
looking sort of a little result I hate
my life I'm achieve that energy imma
chinita energy and achieve that entry
hey watch me pee I'm cheetah energy i'm
tina injuries okay if it was one of the
most dangerous animals me
in Safari you need to never get in front
of the hippo and the water look at those
launches it'll kill you and that was my
impression of their girls remember as
well I'm gonna have to work on that one
just a little bit Hey Dude where we
going man good thing you have a green
exterior you never know when you're
gonna need it hey can you pass backpack
toilet paper
and that my friends is a compilation of
a bunch of our movie clips and my
commentary beeps hi